natalia called nina is a young 26 year
old researcher originally from Ukraine
she now works in a research center in
France an artificial intelligence
specialist she showed how drones can be
piloted using mind control since Marie
Curie became the first woman to receive
the nobel prize for physics in 1911 more
and more women have been pursuing
Scientific careers however today just a
third of researchers in the EU or women
they remain underrepresented in the
research and development field and in
high levels of decision-making girls are
afraid the bits of new technologies it
seems to be occupied by men so I think
in an early stage we have to make them
feel comfortable with the new technology
and then we get even more women in
science almost fifty percent of all PhD
graduate they're actually women but
numerous social and cultural obstacles
prevent women from embarking on a
scientific career path from the PTO bed
among the scientific but ya des choses
qui se solu nuclear crystal a la
francaise physical problem biome de piel
de tois Zemke generation weirdest combat
veggie papers fun ways to solve a
problem la sheegay homilies on clichés
don't be fooled memo swimming is a
lesson year shall defeat and it is
regularly launched initiatives to
encourage women to start careers in
science it's also the objective of the
International Day of women and girls in
the sciences